impeachment day impeachment a ser the
last very excited about impeachment a
there's no reason to even point this out
anymore but I will anyway that you know
you're not supposed to be excited about
a president getting in beached I'm not
saying you have to be opposed to it
every time obviously that's not my point
I'm saying that if you support it the
fact that in your mind a president must
be impeached deserves to deserves to be
impeached in your mind should I would
think engender in you a more more of a
somber feeling okay not a celebratory
one but this is a pointless thing for me
to say I realize we're long past the
point of that kind of maturity of that
kind of sober mindedness the mask has
long been torn off the left wants Trump
out because they hate his guts they just
don't like him and they said from day
one that they want him impeached and now
they're actually doing it it's as simple
as that they were looking for an excuse
they've been searching for an excuse for
three years they finally found one and
and and and they went with it I do worry
I have to say I do worry about where all
of this heads and I don't talk about
impeachment must up much on this show
for reasons I've already explained it's
it's talked about plenty elsewhere
plenty of great analysis I don't feel
like I have to add to it also I think
there are there are things that for me
are more important and and deserve our
focus more but I will say one of the
rare occasions that I talked about the
impeachment mess I will say that I do I
do worry about it as I've always said I
worry about the bigger picture I mean
now as I've always said I don't see
America descending into a civil war I
don't I don't see that happening because
at the end of the day all anybody really
wants to do in this country is binge
Netflix they want to sit on their couch
and binge Netflix that's all anybody
wants to do and having a full-on civil
war will very much interfere with that
and and then also I think are already
our ideological divide in this country
does not have the same geographic
character as it did in the past at least
not quite to the same
stent where you had that clear dividing
line north and south we don't exactly
have that now which would make a civil
war or less logistically feasible but I
am concerned at any rate about the
trajectory were on if you think about
impeachment has historically been a very
very very rare thing it was viewed
historically as a step taken only in the
extremists of circumstances there have
been many corrupt presidents in the past
there have been many presidents who have
done a lot of bad and stupid things
almost all of them were not impeached
because impeachment is last resort the
most extreme thing that that you can do
to a president now this impeachment
motivated plainly by the Democrat Party
is overall revulsion to trump this
impeachment is comes only twenty years
after the last impeachment and
previously before the Clinton
impeachment there had only been two in
history well really actually one I guess
because Nixon resigned before he was
impeached but we'll call that an
impeachment so there have been two in
history in over two centuries of
American history and then and then you
had and then you had Clinton and now
we've got another one twenty years later
so what happens now if Republicans take
control of the house and a Democrat wins
in 2020 or in 2024 or whatever it
happens will Republicans impeach that
person out of revenge I know there's
gonna be there will be among
conservatives I don't think it's right I
don't think that this is what we should
do but I think there's gonna be in fact
I've already seen it
I've already seen a lot of conservatives
online saying next time we get a chance
we're impeaching one of yours and I
think there's gonna be a groundswell of
conservative voters calling for that
because now now a lot of people are in
revenge mode so Democrat gets in you got
a Republican house they're impeached
does impeachment become I guess this is
my concerns as a Pietschmann become a
standard political tool just something
that you do
where does it lead when the opposing
party always tries to remove the
president democratically elected by the
country are we already getting to a
point where that's just the way it goes
you it's it's not just that you if
you're the opposing party you oppose the
president that's always but now you you
try to remove him you try to get him out
of office
I worry about that and speaking of
worries in case you wanted stuff to
worry about this holiday season it's a
great theme for a show up heading into
Christmas all the stuff to worry about
there is a 1.4 trillion dollar spending
bill currently making its way through
Congress and also speaking of other
things that are important besides
impeachment here's one and I want to
talk about there's a lot more to say
about it in just a moment but first a
word from policy genius you know we've
all got our Christmas lists but I'm
guessing that life insurance is not
exactly at the top of it because it's
something that seems daunting it seems
like well it's something that makes you
worried right well here's something that
you don't have to worry about because
policy genius comes in and at least this
is one area of life that gets a lot
easier because you've got policy genius
they'll find the right life insurance at
the best price and do all the work to
help you get covered policy genius makes
finding the right life insurance as easy
as one two three it's a breeze in
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers to find your best price you
could say fifteen hundred dollars or
more by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork they'll handle all the red
tape they're gonna do all that for you
so you don't have to worry about it and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
with all other with with many other
forms of insurance so if you need life
insurance but aren't sure where to start
why not start with policy genius.com it
only takes a few minutes to find the
right life insurance policy apply and
cross another thing off your to-do list
policy genius when it comes to life
insurance it's nice to get it right okay
so while everybody is talking about
impeachment both Republicans and
Democrats are hoping that we don't
notice one point four trillion dollars
this boondoggle that
they're ramming down the public's throat
we read a little bit from The Washington
Post the house on Tuesday approved a one
point four trillion dollar spending
package that would stave off a looming
shutdown and fund the federal government
through September acting in a burst of
bipartisanship just a day before
Democrats plan to impeach President
Trump the legislation would also remove
three controversial taxes from the
Affordable Care Act the package passed
in two pieces one focused on GOP
national security priorities including
the Pentagon the other on domestic
agencies dear Democrats such as the
Department of Health and Human Services
the vote of the national security
package was 282 138 the vote on the
domestic agencies was 297 to 2 or to 120
the legislation would add almost 50
billion dollars in new spending even
though the White House and Republicans
called for major budget reductions
earlier in the year the package will
also strip back parts of the ACA
legislation that many Democrats say
serves as a defining moment the Obama
administration all told the legislation
could add more than 500 billion dollars
to deficits over the next stephane
decade the deficits or annual gap
between government spending and tax
revenue was expected to eclipse one
trillion dollars this year one trillion
dollars in grow and subsequent years
subsequent subsequent that's the way I
pronounce it every time I say subsequent
I get emails you say subsequent its
subsequent note I say subsequent and
that's perfectly valid look it up anyway
one trillion dollars and it's gonna grow
and in subsequent years unless changes
are made okay all I can say is I hope
that we all understand now I'm sure
we've all understood this for a while
right that fiscal conservatism is a myth
doesn't exist it just doesn't exist
there is no fiscally conservative party
there is no movement of fiscal
conservatism it it it's it's not there
it's been a myth for at least 30 years
every Republican president in that span
has run huge deficits and I want you to
think about what a deficit is the
Washington Post explained it if you
didn't know but to reiterate that means
that
government is spending more than it
collects in revenue
all right basic economics but here's
here's why that's significant at this
point the government collects almost
four trillion dollars in revenue I think
2020 it was about 3.7 or it will be
about 3.7 trillion for 2020 so we're
getting to the four trillion mark we're
getting very close to it let's round up
and call it four trillion just for the
sake of argument so that means they're
spending more than four trillion dollars
and that's not enough okay
somehow they can't get everything they
want accomplished with a measly four
trillion collecting four trillion
dollars that's not enough they they need
to spend even more than that four
trillion dollars I mean think about what
four trillion dollars is we're dealing
with numbers that are beyond human
comprehension I think that's one of the
reasons why fiscal conservatism died it
was sort of overwhelmed it died by
overdose because now we're dealing with
numbers that no one can even try
trillion what is a trillion what is a
trillion I have no I
you can't conceptualize that it's such a
massive number that we I think we tune
it out because we can't wrap our heads
around it well here's one way to
conceptualize it collecting four
trillion dollars in revenue is the
equivalent so the government collecting
four trillion dollars in revenue is the
equivalent of the government
confiscating all of the wealth of half
of the world's billionaires if they were
to line up half of the billionaires in
the world take everything that each one
of them is worth that's about four
trillion dollars and it's not enough so
they're doing that every year now every
year the government is spending the
equivalent of all of the wealth of half
of the world's billionaires and they
need to spend even more
so there isn't any party in Washington
and hardly any individual voices in
Washington that care about fiscal
conservatism that's dead that doesn't
exist nobody cares about it there was a
movement of conservatives of there was a
a conservative movement for a little
while I think the Tea Party this was one
of the big focuses of the Tea Party what
happened to that what happened what
happened to the tea party Republicans
concerned about yeah
they got bored with it that's why I'm
often skeptical of these kinds of
movements that pop up people are out
holding signs and I went to some of the
Tea Party rallies back in what was a
2009 or whatever that was and and I
quickly grew weary of it I even went to
some tea party meetings because it
started to seem to me that people just
had fun they just wanted to go out and
hold a sign and feel like they were
doing something then you go to a meeting
and everyone takes turns getting up and
complaining but that's it it just that's
what it seemed like it seemed like
people were having fun it was something
to do was a hobby and sure enough within
ten years yeah nobody cares anymore no
one talks about that stuff anymore
meanwhile lawmakers have stuffed in
stuffed into this bedding bill a
provision tell me if you can see how
this has anything to do with spending
they've stuffed into the bill a
provision that would raise the age to
buy to buy tobacco to 21 as part of a
spending bill they're gonna make it so
you have to be 21 to buy any tobacco
product including e-cigarettes what does
it have to do with spending why wouldn't
this be a separate piece of legislation
that they that they take out and debate
specifically if you want to do that make
it a separate bill debate that passed
that well probably they don't want to
debate it because it's impossible to
justify something like this so let's
just think about this now
you have to be 21 to buy a pack of
cigarettes or once this law passes this
bill this spending bill passes which it
will you have to be 21 to buy it
pack of cigarettes or a vape cartridge
if that's what is that what it is a
cartridge when you vape I don't know
what whatever it is whatever the kids
are doing these days you have to be 21
you you are not according to the
government now you are not old enough or
mature enough to make the decision to
buy a pack of cigarettes or to vape
before the age of 21 but you are old
enough to drive at 16 so at 16 we're
gonna trust you to pilot a 4,000 pound
chunk of metal down the highway at 75
miles an hour we're gonna trust you to
do that you're competent enough for that
but it's gonna be another five years
before you're mature enough to pilot
that five that 4,000 pound chunk of
metal to Rite Aid to buy cigarettes if
right it even still sells cigarettes
which I'm not sure if they do at 18 so
that's that's 16 16 you're already old
enough for that at 18 at 18 we're gonna
trust you to open a bank account we're
gonna trust you to get a tattoo which is
permanently marking your body we're
going to trust you to enlist in the
military we're gonna trust you to go
skydiving we're gonna trust you to serve
on a jury we're gonna trust you to buy
fireworks we're gonna trust you to buy a
shotgun we're gonna trust you to sign
contracts we're gonna trust you to sign
a mortgage we're gonna trust you to get
to to get married we're gonna trust you
to vote but you won't be old enough to
vape for another three years
so you're old enough to do all that
stuff you're not old enough to to vape
that's that no no that's where we draw
the line oh and you can also be executed
by the state so you're so competent Wow
and we expect you to be so confident
that if you commit a serious crime you
could be executed or at a minimum you
can go to federal prison not old enough
though to smoke a cigar not old enough
to smoke a black and milds or to drink a
Bud Light for that matter oh and you're
also old enough to kill your baby in an
abortion so you're old enough to make
that decision
and you're old enough to get plastic
surgery permanently mutilating your body
speaking of which you're old enough to
permanently transition into another
gender well you could do that before 18
now so all of that everything I mean
every responsibility and power and right
imaginable you have and a bunch at some
of which you should not ever have like
the ability to kill your baby but we're
throwing that in too you can do all of
that before 21 most of it at 18 some of
it before that but you're still not old
enough to to buy cigarettes the only
thing left I think of what 25 is when
you can rent a car so that's that's the
only thing left that's the last thing
that's the last thing you're old enough
to do is rent is go to enterprise and
rent a Toyota does any of this make any
sense
is there any theory of human
psychological and emotional development
that can lend any coherence or
credibility to this okay I'd like to
hear from some psychologists to explain
to me exactly how it is that the human
mind is as matured enough at 18 to do
all of that stuff but still it cannot be
trusted the person with that mind cannot
be trusted to stand at the gas station
and have the ability to buy a pack of
camels and now you can't know when I've
talked about this in the past people
will say oh well nobody should be
smoking anyway it's poison okay but
that's an argument for banning it
outright that's not an argument for
raising the age limit and if you think
the tobacco should be banned well then
make that argument I would
wholeheartedly disagree with it but
that's an argument you can make you can
make that argument I don't think that
anyone has a god-given right to buy buy
cigarettes it's nice so it's
theoretically it could be bad I I don't
I absolutely would disagree with that
move but if that's your argument if you
are okay with this or if you justify it
on
basis that it's a horrible thing it's
poison nobody should do it the tobacco
companies are predatory and all that
stuff yada yada those all of that those
are all arguments for prohibition those
are not arguments for raising the age
limit arbitrarily to 21 now I know where
to get a million emails that say but you
said porn should be banned yes
and I will and I have already repeatedly
defended my assertion that porn is far
more harmful far more of a danger to
society and to children and to people
that are involved in it than tobacco
products are you disagree with me if you
want that's fine but my position is at
least intellectually consistent it's not
arbitrary that's not nothing arbitrary
about it arbitrary would be me saying
well I think poins a terrible thing it's
very harmful and so therefore the porn
the age for viewing or purchasing
pornography should be raised to 37 that
would be arbitrary and intellectually
dishonest why 37 why not 21 what at 18
well that's 16 I mean why are we drawing
these lines exactly I'm not saying that
there's no reason to draw a line I'm
just saying you have to have a reach you
there must you must present what the
reason is there could be a good reason
I'm not arguing that the children should
have the right to do all of these things
at any age it's definitely not my my
opinion but there there should be a
discernible reason that you can present
based partly or largely in human
psychology to defend whatever age limit
you've come up with for whatever the
thing is
if you want to argue for tobacco
prohibition then make that argument and
I'll explain why you're wrong but don't
tell me that it makes sense to raise the
age from to 21 from 18 when all of these
other things can be done at 18 other
things including by the way looking at
in purchasing pornography there as I
mentioned there's there's another thing
you can do at 18 but again not mature
enough to vape you need another three
years of maturity for that which which
which means we have people voting and
driving and buying guns and convicting
their fellow citizens of crimes think
about what's serving on a jury means
means we're trusting your judgment to
decide if someone should go to prison or
worse so so there are people doing that
driving buying shotguns convicting
people on juries all that's up being
convicted of crimes themselves and sent
to prison or to death row there are
people doing that who are not competent
enough to wield a vape pen according to
the law as it stands right now or as it
will stand once this spending bill
signed that's what the laws think does
it make sense no it doesn't but here's
something that does make sense this
holiday season do your friends and
family a solid by getting them a daily
wire gift membership and the good news
for you is that from now until January
1st all insider plus gift memberships
are 25% off that means your loved ones
will get all the fantastic perks plus
the majestic glorious beautiful
triumphant leftist tears tumbler and
you'll get the savings so they get the
tumbler you get the savings that's 25%
off all insider plus gift memberships
this holiday season go to daily
wired.com slash gift to get your twenty
five percent off deal again that's daily
wire.com slash gift to get your twenty
five percent off give them a gift
they'll thank you for all year long by
the way they're talking about I don't
know if you've seen this they're talking
about now doing an all-female Fight Club
that's the latest reboot in the works an
all-female Fight Club now this obviously
is stupid it's not gonna work for one
thing this is yet again Hollywood
pandering to the
whoa crowd by appropriating popular
stories and trying to feminize them
rather than just making new stories
telling new stories having women's star
in those stories you want to tell a
story that involves women fighting fine
go ahead and tell that story it doesn't
need to be a female Fight Club so it's
very dumb and for another Fight Club is
is to its core a male movie that that's
part a whole point of the thing you just
you cannot remove the testosterone from
that movie while still having it be
Fight Club in any in any distinguishable
sense so a Fight Club without men that
would be like a Mean Girls remake
without girls which come to think of it
Mean Girls is already kind of the female
fight clubs I don't know why you need
you need this but here's the bigger
problem this is this is really my point
and this is this is the the issue with
this that no one else is gonna point out
so I feel like I have to what's the
first rule of Fight Club we've all seen
the movie what's the first rule of Fight
Club you don't talk about Fight Club so
there is no way women could ever follow
that rule it would never happen you you
know that rule is gonna be obliterated
on the first day there is no way you
could have a bunch of women and
something like Fight Club and they're
not coming home and telling their
husbands and their boyfriends all about
it the very first day it would not take
a lot of prodding it really wouldn't
they would come home the first day
oh my gosh the craziest thing happened
today oh yeah what was it I can't tell
you it's a it's a rule I just I can't
say it okay well you know off the tongue
no seriously I just I can't tell you I
really can't I'd be in so much trouble I
promise that I went up all right that's
fine you know what so okay fine so I
joined this thing called Fight Club and
oh my god this girl Tyler
she started but I think she might be a
projection of my own personality because
I'm going insane but anyway there's this
girl there she's really fat and and that
would be the end of the movie that's
just that's the end of the female Fight
Club it might be kind of interesting
though come to think of it let's go to
emails Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
wall show at gmail.com now that I've
given the
Media Matters monitors of this show
that's gonna be there that's gonna be
there pull for this for this show that's
that's the ones gonna end up on Twitter
daily wire host goes on sexist rampage
daily wire host goes I'll give you the
what the headline is for Twitter made
Media Matters daily wire host goes on
sexist rant about female Fight Club
reboot there it is
put it up Matt well show at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com this is
from Paul says you asked why would you
give your money to someone who hates you
Christian's still patronized Starbucks
people have no spines when it affects
their appetite
Paul's referring to what we talked about
yesterday with Netflix they are
streaming this grotesque absurdly
intentionally offensive quote-unquote
comedy special that portrays Jesus as a
gay man and machines and the point that
I made yesterday and a lot of people
have made is okay Netflix has every
right to stream this kind of material if
they want to but that is obviously a
statement to their Christian customers
and the statement is we hate you we have
no respect for you we don't want your
money
and if a company is gonna send that
message to to you as a customer then it
makes sense to say all right well then
I'm not gonna give you my money if you
don't want it I won't give it to you if
I walk in the door metaphorically and
you spit in my face okay you know I'm
not I'm not gonna give you my money it's
not even a boycott it's not a boycott
it's not about making a statement the
statement has been made by Netflix in
this case they made the statement by
streaming this content and Paul says
there are other companies as well and
that's true of course I think you know I
have long been opposed to boycott
culture and boycott culture is this
thing where a new company is being
boycotted every other day and companies
are being boycotted for frivolous
reasons
these are being boycotted because
somebody in the company made a political
statement or there's some it is some
kind of tangential peripheral thing
where the company through a maze of
connections is being connected to some
ideological point that other that a
group of customers don't like and so
they say we're gonna blow up that kind
of thing and that I think is frivolous
and stupid and I'm opposed to it but I
do also think that again if a company is
is is making a statement is making a
point to the customer saying if you are
this kind of customer we really don't
like you we have no respect for you then
yeah I mean of course you're gonna
you're not you give you money to
somebody else not them you put Starbucks
in that category see I don't really
think I would put Starbucks I think that
Starbucks is a liberally oriented
company that's for sure
as far as a company that goes out of its
way to insult Christians I don't think
so unless you're gonna go with the
Starbucks cup thing well they don't have
religious imagery on their cups instead
they just have snowflakes that's like
Happy Holidays if that's what you're
going with III would say I don't think
that's anti-christian at all and and
actually I don't even know if this if
this is if that was if that's what you
were referring to but as far as that
goes I may be unique not entirely unique
but I'm in the minority anyway among
Christians in that it seems like I'm in
the minority anyway among Christians
that I don't need when I go to the store
whether I'm going to get a coffee I'm go
to the grocery store or I'm at a
restaurant whatever it is I don't need
the employee to say Merry Christmas to
me it's not a big deal to me if they say
Happy Holidays III don't need specific
Christian decorations in the store if
they want to go the secular more
crowd-pleasing general route with with
just doing snowflakes NACA and snowman
and everything that's fine I don't need
edge I don't need it I don't really
understand when people why people do I
don't really understand why I think it's
really stupid and dumb when people on
the
get offended by Merry Christmas and some
and they do sometimes get offended by
Merry Christmas in fact there was
someone on Twitter yesterday complaining
thing was a it was a very blue check to
verified account so you know they're
important complaining that Neil Gorsuch
was on Fox & Friends and said Merry
Christmas
does someone really offended by that
okay so that's that's definitely a thing
and that's very stupid and what it's a
call that overly sensitive would be
would be way under selling it but it's
also stupid in my mind and this also
happens where you have some Christians
or get kind of upset when they hear the
Happy Holidays and making a point oh no
we should say Merry Christmas
who cares doesn't matter it is it is a
holiday see there are other holidays
Hanukkah is a holiday and depending on
where you are now look if you're if
you're at a Walmart in I don't know Fort
Smith or something yeah probably every
customer going in there celebrates
Christmas and so you might as well say
Merry Christmas but if you're you know
like I grew up in where I grew up in
Maryland it was a it was a probably
still majority Christian area but there
was a heavy Jewish population or other
people of other faith traditions and so
you know you work at a company there
people are coming in there's a pretty
good chance they're not Christian and so
why would you say Merry Christmas when
there's a good chance you're talking to
someone doesn't celebrate the holidays
just going to be kind of weird so what's
wrong with saying happy holidays and
being more general it's not that you're
trying not to offend people
it just seems more sensible certainly if
you know that someone's not Christian
you're not gonna say Merry Christmas to
them right that would be weird
not offensive just strange you wouldn't
go up to a Christian and say Happy
Hanukkah so I I think the whole I think
I'm Paul you didn't even bring this up
so I may be way off the track here with
what you meant to whatever you're
referring to with with Starbucks being
anti-christian I would you let me know I
don't know what example you're talking
about but as for this Christmas thing I
think on both sides it's just it's
absurd everyone needs to relax
doesn't matter happy holidays Merry
Christmas whatever doesn't take anything
away from my celebration okay
we're celebrating Christmas in my house
whatever Walmart or Starbucks does or
however they decorate the the grocery
store or the mall doesn't has no effect
on me doesn't matter
case from Jacob says hi Matt you discuss
the other day the adoption of embryos
verse human children and how priority
should be given to the life with a
consciousness and life experience I have
heard arguments from the left about what
to do if a box of a thousand viable
embryos and a three and a three year old
child were both trapped in a burning
building and you had to choose which to
save I understand that just because you
would save one doesn't mean the other
isn't a life but it seems many
conservatives would agree that the three
olds life is worth more and should
therefore be saved my question is do you
think the three-year-olds life is worth
more and if so what distinguishes
current consciousness of the child from
the potentiality for all of those
experiences and consciousness of the
embryos it seems to me that if we are to
value life inside the womb we would want
to value it just as highly as life
outside thanks so much for your time and
I love listening to show every day after
school god bless well Jacob you're not
wrong in anything you said in fact I
think you sort of as you were asking the
question you worked through it yourself
and kind of answered it and the answer
is that yes if you're trapped in a
burning building and this is a classic
hypothetical put forward by pro-abortion
people a lot even though it doesn't
prove anything and that's always been my
response to this hypothetical it proves
nothing yes if I'm trapped in a burning
building and somehow for some reason
there's a box of embryos and a child I
don't know what scenario I would ever be
and where both of those things would be
in the same room and it's burning but
for the sake of the argument yeah you
would save the three-year-old shot I
think anyone would you would you would
be it would be psychotic so if you could
only choose one to leave the child there
screaming to burn to death while
grabbing a box of embryos I don't think
anyone would do that anybody would grab
the child I certainly would but as you
said yourself that does not at all
demonstrate that that the that the the
the life you chose not to save isn't a
life doesn't mean that
and I would also say you're talking
about well which one is worth more it
also doesn't mean that one is worth more
intrinsically I would agree with you
that if if human life has intrinsic
value intrinsic means belonging to a
thing by its very nature right so if we
have intrinsic value as human beings if
me as a 33 year old man I'm 33 right or
am i 32 have to ask my wife think I'm 33
as a 33 year old man if I have intrinsic
value that means it's part of my very
nature which means if it's part of my
nature it's integral it's its it cannot
be taken away it cannot be gained at any
point it's been with me ever since I
existed as a being from the very first
moment that I was a being existing in
any form I must have had that intrinsic
worth if I didn't have it then then I
can't possibly have intrinsic worth now
you could say that I have some other
kind of subjective worth but I don't
believe that humans have just subjective
worth I think they have intrinsic worth
so if we haven't translate worth if we
you if you believe that then you must
believe that human embryos have
intrinsic worth too but this
hypothetical doesn't touch on that has
nothing to do with it and I think the
way to demonstrate that Jakob is with
another hypothetical let's say you were
in a burning building maybe something a
little bit more realistic though still
improbable let's say you were in a
burning building there's a three year
old child there and a 87 year old man
with terminal cancer and you could only
save one which one are you gonna save
well I think most people would save the
child right probably the the 87 year old
man would say save the child even if he
didn't even if they're both pleading and
you could only save one you're gonna
save the child that's not the same as
killing it's let's be clear about this
also just because you save one doesn't
doesn't mean in any way that you killed
or brought about the death of the other
person you just were only able to save
one you would like to say both you
couldn't
but if you save the three old child does
that mean that the 87 year old man with
terminal cancer isn't a human life no
does it mean that his life is worth less
no not at all not at all not even a
little bit it's just that you had to
make the decision based on other things
you weren't making it based on which is
a life you weren't making it based on
whose life is worth more those are not
your considerations and I would venture
to say in that moment that's also that
that's not it's not gonna all be what
you're thinking yeah I gotta sit there
think well which life is worth more
which one of these is more human than
the other no you're not thinking that
probably in the moment it's more of an
instinctive choice it's an emotional
choice and and if you have any there's
any thought process at all you're gonna
think well you know this child has the
potential to live a long and healthy
life if I save him this old man is
unfortunately you know at the end of his
life anyway and so it's a horrible
choice to have to make but it just seems
like the most just thing to do is to
save the child and so you make a similar
calculation I think with the embryos
although on a little bit of a different
basis I think the basis there is partly
well this child has the capacity for
suffering that the embryos probably do
not so I'm going to leave to leave the
child theirs is to consign him to a
horrific Allah painful death that he
will suffer and feel and also this child
if you save the child and you bring him
out of the building he's gonna probably
go on barring tragedy he's gonna go on
to live a life you know just gonna he's
gonna walk off and go to his parents and
continue living whereas with the embryos
frozen embryos I mean who knows what
will happen they could end up being
destroyed anyway and there's there's
nothing there's no guarantee at all that
all of these embryos are going to go on
to be implanted in a womb and you know
develop and and you know have an actual
live an actual life in that sense
you might make the determination based
on that as well but these are again none
of it has anything to do with the
question of of intrinsic worth or
anything like that thanks for the
question though from Sam says on Sunday
at my youth group my leader gave a talk
about whether or not we should allow LGB
deep LGBT people into the church I being
a conservative and Catholic said that
while we should have compassion and
respect to these people we should not
let them be a part of the church because
their choices go against Christian
teachings while everyone else said that
the church needs to change with the
times and learn that it's okay to live
your life like that I'm curious to know
your thoughts on this and I should go
about expressing more traditional
opinions should I go back expressing
more traditional opinions with this
group because it doesn't seem like these
people really agree with me on most
things well same I'm a little bit
concerned about this conversation you
had with your youth group because it
sounds like your youth group leader
unless something was lost in translation
here which is possible it sounds like
your youth group leader presented a one
heck of a false choice here one choice
is it seems they're not allowed in the
church at all the other choice is we
abandon our our you know biblical
teaching then in our moral code and we
say that
it sounds like from what you've
presented those were the two choices
given when in reality those are not at
all the two choices of course we let
anyone into the church if anyone can can
come into church we welcome all people
especially sinners because everyone is
right so now we welcome everyone into
the church the question is when it comes
to biblical teaching when it comes to
the teachings of Jesus Christ what comes
to the teachings of the church for the
last 2000 years
do we abandon those just because they
are difficult or just because they're
offensive to certain people and the
answer there is no so I think that's how
you split the difference there we
welcome everyone into a church we don't
abandon the moral teachings
for anybody by the way not just for for
for gay people I mean there are anyone
that comes into the church and is living
their life in a certain way or would
prefer if you know a certain thing
wasn't considered a sin because it makes
their life would no we don't we don't we
should not be compromising on any level
phyleus is from the res says oh wise and
highly revered future Supreme Leader
eight months ago I became a mom to an
awesome little girl parenting is by far
the greatest thing I've ever done or
ever will do it is amazing and
miraculous behind beyond comprehension
explanation but I'm sure you don't need
me to tell you that on the flip side
though parenting has made me acutely
aware of my own personal shortcomings I
tend to be very logical practical
generally serious creativity for me
presents itself in the form of a very
well executed Excel spreadsheet
basically I completely lack imagination
this becomes glaring in my efforts to
not speak to my eight month old as if
she is an adult to play games with her
to give her toy voices and to give her
toys voices and storylines etc I humbly
ask if this is something that you
struggle with as a parent and if so do
you have any suggestions and had to be
more imaginative and creative with her
now as she gets older well I would say
first of all I've struggled with many
things as a pair pretty much everything
has been a struggle for me but what I
would say here is if you're if your
greatest flaw as a parent at this point
early on in your journey is that you're
too organized
then you're in really good shape I would
say don't worry about it all really
don't I wish I had this this idea of I
don't even know what if I couldn't even
begin to make a spreadsheet I don't know
what it looks like I can't even wrap my
head around that
so as someone with no organizational
capacity whatsoever when I look at you
I'm deeply envious
so I'm doubly mind my first answer is
don't don't worry too much about it but
the other thing is listen you should
it's use eight months old at 8 months
old
there's playing games with an 8 month
old there's not a little there's not a
lot of she can really do in terms of
playing games she's just not there yet
cognitively so I think the most
important thing at 8 months old is just
that it sounds like this is what you're
already doing you love your child ok
obviously you're spending time with her
you're giving her that bonding and so
that's it I really wouldn't worry about
it as long as you're spending a lot of
time with her and you're giving her that
love and affection which it sounds like
you're doing in spades then it really
doesn't it's ok that's that's all she
really needs as she gets older as a
child gets older that's when playing
becomes more important and more active
and more participatory I suppose and I
do think you want to play with the child
but I'll tell you what I do now in some
I say I struggle with everything as a
parent I don't struggle quite as much
with this what you're talking about
because I'm I have the opposite problem
of you I'm not organized I'm also I
think at the end of the day deeply
immature so I have no problem playing
childish games with my kids because I
kind of enjoyed them too so you know we
the other day we went down and played
Flores lava and I had a blast it was
just fun it was fun to do so I miss
playing floors I mean it's a lot of fun
you pretend on the floors lobby you're
jumping from thing to thing not played
that with the kids if you're more of an
adult than I am which it sounds like you
are that might not come as naturally to
you but here's what I would say as the
child gets older I think when it comes
to playing with the child yeah you could
try to incorporate yourself into the
things that they do as children which is
important but it's also really important
to incorporate them into the things that
you do so you find things that you enjoy
and you you say was a girl you your
daughter you incorporate your daughter
into those things and I do that with my
kids as well
because yeah there are some childish
games that I enjoy playing but much that
I don't it does get boring after a while
and I think after a while the kids can
tell that you're sort of bored even if
you're faking it
so think about things you like to do it
just have them do that with you I think
that's very important for the kid
they're gonna learn a lot from that
they're gonna learn a lot from seeing
you do the things you're passionate
about and they're gonna be thrilled by
the fact that you're incorporating them
into that no matter what it is doesn't
matter what it is even things like what
we watch on TV like if I'm gonna sit
down and watch TV with my kids I'm sorry
I'm not sitting down and watching Peppa
Pig with my kid I'm just not doing it I
can't maybe that's not their flaw as a
parent I don't have the patience but I
can't sit down and watch a kids show
with kids I absolutely cannot do it I
cannot stomach it so I'll find something
that I am interested in watching that's
appropriate and I'll have them watch it
with me and they love it and you know
because they develop those same
interests and they can tell that I am
interested in it so that makes them
interested so for me one thing
especially in Saturday mornings a lot of
times we'll sit down we'll watch a
nature documentary I like nature
documentaries it's educational kids love
it and so we'll sit there for an hour
and we'll watch a documentary about ants
in the jungle or whatever and they can
tell I'm interested it gives us
something to talk about and it's a
win-win for everybody but
congratulations by the way on on
motherhood sounds like you're off to a
good start we'll leave it there thanks
I'm ready for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me
Andrew Clayton
[Music]